joining us now is newt gingrich former
speaker of the house and fox news
contributor
newt has there ever been
a less consequential president
managing a more incompetent senior
leadership in modern american history
oh i don't think there's ever been in
all of american history
anyone who
in two or three weeks
has done the amount of damage that joe
biden has done
this is an astonishing performance
i don't think you and i could have
imagined it as a novel
here's a guy who goes in takes a totally
winnable position throws it away
positions the americans so they can't
defend themselves then decides that he
really has to owe our enemies people we
fought for 20 years they're now our
allies overnight and so he has to do
what they tell him to do they instruct
him when to leave and they instruct him
by the way while keeping 85 billion
dollars
of american equipment uh you this whole
thing is is sending signals around the
entire planet that
biden is hopeless that the united states
is out of the game and it's dangerous
because you could imagine china making a
grab at taiwan you can imagine the north
korean dictatorship deciding to be dead
to do something
the iranians have indicated they want to
do war games in the gulf
with both china and russia which would
be very dangerous for us
all these things have gone on
you could also imagine putin deciding to
do something very aggressive in ukraine
this is not just a one-off brief moment
in history
this is a man who is broken
a sense of risk of respect a sense of
reliability which we built from pearl
harbor day on in december 7th 1941 so
we've had that entire period
where the world came to believe the
united states kept its word the united
states was powerful the united states
had to be feared and now we're being led
by somebody uh who looks like a totally
scared bunny rabbit uh on the in danger
of falling asleep and his performance at
dover
that may have been the most
disrespectful you know when when
gold star families attack the president
uh you know
something's really sick yeah and one of
the sickness is called joe biden yeah it
wasn't political it was heartfelt it was
it was common sense and it was heartfelt
uh and we're gonna share another story
tonight of a mom who's grieving uh after
joe biden's incompetence uh last week
but newt i want to play this for you
because again totally untethered to
reality joe biden
wants people to believe that we're
actually safer
because of his incompetence
as we close 20 years of war and strife
and pain and
sacrifice it's time to look at the
future
not the past
to future that's safer
to future that's more secure
now did this catastrophic uh management
of this pull-out make us position to be
safer in the future
i don't think anybody on the planet
except hard-line left-wing democrats
believes that
the fact is the way this happened
makes america much more at risk you have
you have an open southern border you
have at least 5 000 terrorists who've
been released from prison at bagram you
have
all sorts of people flowing across
national borders the europeans are
braced for a huge wave of people coming
in they don't know how many of them will
be terrorists and if you're a terrorist
this is the greatest victory in the long
war with the west that you've seen in
the last 50 or 60 years i mean
every young terrorist on the planet
is going to think it's you know well
let's get out there and kill somebody
let's get out there and destroy
something
and i frankly worry about 911 from that
perspective these guys aren't going to
sit around and do nothing you know
they're not going to say i'm really glad
that the americans left now i think i'll
be calm and peaceful they're going to
take all that equipment
and they're going to send it all over
the planet now it's all disabled news
and they can't get yeah they can't use
it at all it's all disabled that's what
we're that's where we're led i don't
believe anything the biden team is
telling us about vetting refugees about
the disabled equipment about the
collateral damage of killing all these
kids with the drug i don't i don't
believe any of this until it's verified
but new we gotta roll
your friend
no administration in american history
has lied as blatantly right as openly
as the biden administration and that's
where you start i mean if you if you
don't understand they lie to you all day
all the time every day i'm newt it's
great to see you tonight thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else